hello there I'm virtually andrew heaton
and this boat is and is not
mostly weekly political parties which
comes to us from the Latin Paulito
spartak a meaning to screw over
historically political parties have been
dedicated to pretending that they are
consistent and dedicated but since the
2016 election Republicans are acting
like Democrats and Democrats are acting
like Republicans it's almost as if
they've been Freaky Friday like in one
of those hockey movies where people
switch bodies think about it
Republicans are protectionists Democrats
are defending free trade Republicans
want a woman in power Democrats hate a
woman in power Republicans are in bed
with the Soviets megyn kelly is hosting
The Today Show
Trump's on The Tonight Show dogs and
cats living together massive failure in
Republican sex scandals are heterosexual
that used to be the other side's thing
when I was a kid
Republicans had wholesome homosexual sex
scandals whatever happening consistency
that's not even including all of Donald
Trump's reversals Mark Cuban he's a
saint he's the best shark on Shark Tank
no I'm not a Republican but I am
ethnically Republican I was born on a
golf course wearing khaki and I greeted
my mother with a firm handshake but when
I went to college there are only two
options Democrat or virgin so I guess
you could say I've been a Democrat three
times what happened after college you
ask well as the saying goes if you're
young and a conservative you have no
heart and if you're old and liberal you
have no brain and if you're libertarian
you believe you should be able to sell
your organs for profit on an open market
so I was born with a good credit rating
but I experimented with vegetarianism in
college I have swung both ways yet now
the parties are switching places I
thought parties were supposed to stand
for something damn it
consistency is important what else but a
Freaky Friday scenario can account for
Republicans reversing their position on
states rights Republicans didn't want
laws made by some corrupt [ __ ] in
Washington DC they wanted laws made by
some low
corrupt [ __ ] and now Attorney General
Jeff Sessions wants to crack down on
states that legalize marijuana
Republicans spent the last eight years
lambasted executive orders but now that
Trump a Republican is issuing dozens of
them Republicans are suspiciously quiet
once again consistency is important so
Republicans are acting against states
rights which is a pretty strange
about-face almost as if Chuck Schumer
and Mitch McConnell made a wish to trade
places over a cursed fortune cookie wiki
right here but what does it matter that
Republicans and Democrats have Freaky
Friday Dan changed places
it doesn't spending will still stay high
wires will still be tapped and I will
never find true love
it's like if 9/11 conspiracy theorists
and flat-earthers switch places for the
day they'd still be wrong they would
have just swapped positions
unlike libertarians who have been
consistently principled often to the
point of exhaustion for decades
libertarians have stood for legalizing
pot gay marriage welcoming immigrants
free markets and polling it two percent
that's consistency well thanks for
watching mostly weekly i'm andrew heaton
consistently
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
music